well hey everyone its volgen so I took a  break for a while because I had to work  and I'm working on SCP stuff again I'm  working on about three at once as i'm  recording this i'm not sure when they're  going to be out but they're gonna be  cool so the main reason why I'm making  this video is because soon I'm going to  do another FAQ video but this one is  going to be different because this one  is going to have actual clips of people  asking me questions now I can hear you  asking already [ __ ] how do i get into  FAQ video well i'll tell you all you  have to do is make a video response to  this video asking me a question and i'll  put you in the next video if I like the  question or if it doesn't have too many  cuss words in it so if you could do that  that would be cool goodbye  you